And to some degree, we've also talked about access control.
What's left to discuss now are integrity controls and also digital signatures.
And you'll see that the two are really related to each other.
In fact, addressing digital signatures which address non-repudiation requires us to take
care of integrity first.
So what we're going to talk about in this section are what are called message integrity
controls that cryptography can help for us.
Now if you'll remember, what integrity means from a cryptography perspective is if I send
you a message, what I need to do is I need to do something with that message first from
an integrity perspective or from a cryptography perspective to come up with the representation
of the message that I'm sending you.
And then what I do is I send you the message, but I also send you that representation along
with it.
So that when you receive the message and the representation, you will take just the
message, put it through the same integrity algorithm that I did to come up with a representation
of what you've received.
And then you will compare that with the one that I sent you.
And if the two values match, it means that nothing happened along the way.
The whole purpose of message integrity controls is to identify when something happens along
the way.
And what could happen along the way could be due to someone intentionally changing it
or maybe errors happened along the way.
But regardless of what causes the change, we want to be able to identify when it gets
to you.
So that's what all message integrity controls do.
And what they rely on are integrity controls that focus on cryptography.
It's called one way encryption.
One way encryption takes a message or a data of any length, for example.
And we'll always produce a small representation of the entire thing, which can be useful in
identifying, for example, changes when we send or we store something.
So the idea of integrity controls is pretty simple.
And I'm going to illustrate that by using this example here.
Let's say this is the data that I want to send you.
The whole purpose of integrity controls is to take the entire thing, do something to it
mathematically to come up with the representation of the entire thing.
But by using a small value, something that is really small.
And I think if you look at this, you can probably come up with a way that we can, for example,
look at this entire data to come up with the one digit number that really represents
the entire thing.
In fact, if we look at this, if we add all of the digits and use that as the representation,
we come up with a number nine.
But the number nine is a one digit number that really represents the entire message.
And so what I do now is I send you this, the message, but I also send you this representation.
And by the way, this representation is usually referred to as a digest or a message digest.
Both I think is what you might see on the exam.
But it is that representation, that small representation of the entire message.
So I send you the message and the digest along with it.
So let's say that it gets to you and nothing happened along the way.
So I sent you this and the nine, you ended up getting the exact same thing and the nine.
So what you do now is you're going to take what you've received and put it through the
same mathematical process that I did.
So you're going to add up the digits.
You're going to get the number nine and then you're going to compare it to the one that
I sent you.
And if the two values match, it means that nothing happened along the way.
Because if something had happened along the way, let's say the first digit changed.
For example, let's say that I sent you this and the nine, but the first digit changed
to a two, let's say.
So I sent you this, you end up getting this.
When you add up the digits here, you're going to get a different value than the one that
I sent you.
And so when you compare those two values, you're going to say, oh, the two values do not
match.
Digests do not match.
You're going to call me back and say, John, please re-send the information something
happened along the way.
We've been able to identify integrity problems in transmission.
That's what the whole point of integrity controls really are to identify when something
changes, either purposely or unintentionally.
But regardless of what caused the change, we've been able to identify it.
Now one more thing to illustrate this, and that is to illustrate here.
And that is that our method of doing this is not good enough, right?
We need to use better math, for example, that is more sensitive to very small bit changes.
You obviously want these mathematical processes to be very sensitive.
Because in our case, let's say the first two digits changed.
Let's say I sent you this and the nine, but you end up getting this and the nine.
When you add up the digits here, you're going to get the same number, the same digest that
I sent.
But the two messages are actually different, aren't they?
And so because our mathematical process here is not good enough, then it's not able
to identify everything that could happen to your data.
So you want these methods to be much better than what we're using here.
In fact, what we have illustrated here, when you have two different messages that produce
the same digest, that is what is referred to as a collision in cryptography.
And the word collision actually can only be in reference to hashing algorithms or integrity
controls.
We cannot use that word anywhere else in cryptography.
So this is basically the function that all message integrity controls provide for us.
And if we turn to the next slide here, you're going to see that there are a whole bunch
of different integrity controls that exist out there.
And it's represented on your slide here.
So for example, we have parity protection.
We have hashing functions.
We have check sums.
We have CRC checks.
We have message authentication codes.
What's the difference between all of them?
Well, the difference is in the math that they use to come up with the number or that small
representation that really represents the data itself.
Some use better math than others, all right?
Some are very simple.
Like for example, CRC checks use very simple math.
So do check sums and message authentication codes.
The ones that use the best math are the ones that we're going to focus on from this point
on.
And they are called hashing algorithms.
And hashing algorithms are things like, and I'm sure you've heard of these, MD5 and
Shaw for example.
So the hashing algorithms are the ones that use the best math because we want them to be
very sensitive to small bit changes because these will take any size or arbitrary length input
and always produce a digest that is very small, but you want them to be able to identify
very small bit changes.
And those are what we call hashing algorithms like MD5 and Shaw 1.
So hashing functions is sometimes what they're also called, but hashing algorithms I think
is pretty standard as far as the industry is concerned.
And what they do and here's what you need to remember about hashing algorithms is that
they will always take a message of any length.
It doesn't matter if it's one word, one email for example, or your entire hard drive.
They take arbitrary length input and always produce a fixed length digest.
And so if we focus on the two that are very important here, you'll know that MD5
will always produce a 128 bit digest for example.
Shaw will always produce a 160 bit digest.
So at least Shaw 1, you'll see that there's different versions of Shaw that we're going
to talk about coming up here.
And so again, if the message is very large, it will always also produce a fixed sized
result.
And in fact, it doesn't matter what you put into it, it will always produce that fixed
size result, which is referred to as the digest itself.
Now for these, to be really good, and that's why they are really good, we've already said
that they do use the best math.
But that also means that the way that these hashing algorithms have been developed is that
they address some really important characteristics and elements that make them really good.
For example, they have to be one way.
And what they mean by one way is that we can take a message of any length and produce
that digest, but nobody can take that digest and work backwards to be able to disclose,
for example, what the message look like, they can only go one way.
Deterministic means that if you take the same message twice and you hash it using the
exact same hashing algorithm, it will always produce the same digest, no matter how many
times you do it.
It will always produce the same digest, and that's obviously very important.
These hashing algorithms also need to look at the entire message in order to come up
with that digest, because if they don't, the part that they don't look at can change
and you'd never be able to identify messages that have changed, for example.
Uniformly distributed simply means that they're available everywhere.
There's a lot of crypto systems that have these hashing algorithms built in that will
allow any two parties, for example, to address integrity very easily.
They are widely accessible and available for all kinds of different applications.
As we illustrated before, collisions are not good in integrity controls.
These hashing algorithms do resist collisions really well, although the opportunity for
collisions will never totally go away.
The experts in this industry tell us that because you're always taking a message of any
length and always producing something that is very small, the opportunity for collisions
will always be possible, but you want these to resist that as much as possible.
The ones that are the use the most often and are the most popular is what you see on
this slide.
By far, MD5 is the most commonly used hashing algorithm out there.
There's other versions of it, for example, MD2, MD4, MD5 came along, it's like the historical
evolution of these.
We also have MD6 today, although MD5 is still the standard for a lot of applications.
Shaw1, as we said before, is also very popular, produces a digest of 160 bits and you may
have to remember the size of the digest that is produced by each of these hashing algorithms.
There is what we call Shaw3, which has become the standard for many applications that require
a lot more security and that includes a number of versions of the Shaw algorithm and some
of them are Shaw256, Shaw384, Shaw512, for example, that number indicates the size
of the digest that is being produced by that particular version of Shaw.
One of the questions that you might see somewhere is what's the advantage of using a longer
digest and the obvious answer to that is that you will have less collisions.
The longer the digest, the less opportunity for collisions and that's why some of these
are very popular.
In fact, a collision is what we're trying to show you here on this slide where you have
two different messages that produce the exact same digest and that's what we'd refer
to as collision and good hashing algorithms will and should resist that as much as possible,
especially these ones and the better versions of Shaw that are collected within that Shaw3
algorithm that we talk about there.
Now, one of the things that you may see on the exam that we're going to talk about in
more detail later is something called the birthday paradox that relates to something
called the birthday attack.
You need to remember that the birthday attack is a attack that people have come up with
against hashing algorithms like MD5 and Shaw1, for example.
What they try and do is they try and use the math that the birthday paradox uses and
if you know anything about this, it goes something like this.
If you have a room of 23 people, that's the magic number.
The chance that two of those people, any two of those people share the same birthday is
actually greater than 50% at that point and as you start adding more people in the room,
the opportunity or the probability that two people share the same birthday in that room
will actually grow exponentially to the point where you only need 60 people in a room
to have the probability be 99% that any two of those people in that room share the same
birthday.
By birthday, we mean month and day, not year.
This is referred to as the birthday paradox.
You can Google it and there's all kinds of videos that have been made about this pretty
cool math.
The bottom line here is that there is a specific attack against hashing algorithms that people
have devised that basically uses the same math to find, guess what, different messages
that produce the same digest, which is a collision.
So what you need to remember as far as this is concerned, just remember birthday attack,
hashing algorithms, collisions, if you see any one of those, think of the others and it
should give you the answer to the exam question.
But the math called the birthday attack is something that uses the birthday paradox math
to be able to try and find collisions with different messages.